the biggest threat to america today in
my opinion is
the domestic loss of confidence in the
idea of america
how did we get here i mean think about
why the soviet union collapsed it was
not blown up it collapsed because it
lost its morale
it lost its reason for being what is the
true motive to want to lead american to
socialistic ideology
they have inculcated in them that
capitalism is unjust
typically us watching other countries
being divided but today it's other
countries watching america
saying what the hell is going on the
same people who say things like
trump is a dictator trump is an
authoritarian
are the kind of people who love trump
the false message is believed to be true
because of the enormous power of the
media who do you really trust on media
when i did the obama documentary i was
you know taking on the most powerful man
in the world a
socialist society is a society of misery
and tyranny
we're gonna have drones monitoring your
movements if you
don't wear a mask we want your neighbors
to kind of call in on you i mean think
about this
these are the staple moves of a
socialist country the only question is
when something has been tried
25 times across two-thirds of the world
and failed every single time what makes
you think it's going to succeed now if
america becomes socialistic who wins who
loses
everybody loses in the end
[Music]
so my guest today is dinesh de souza
he's a new york times bestseller he's
written many books at the same time he's
produced some extremely controversial
documentaries that have done well
uh one in 2012 called obama's america
which the budget was two and a half
million it did 33 plus million dollars
another one was 2014 called
america imagine the world without her
then 2016 was hillary's america then
2018 was death of a nation
and the latest documentary that's coming
out called trump card which i had a
chance to watch myself
it's not come out yeah by the time this
video comes out hopefully you'll be
playing
at a theater near you with that being
said dinesh thank you so much for being
a guest on valuetainment
uh my pleasure looking forward to it so
dinesh
how did we get here you know you're an
immigrant i'm an immigrant
you came from bombay i came from iran it
was a dream for us to come to america i
came here with this idea
that my life's gonna change the day i
come here i remember the day i landed in
america was november 28 1990
but it seems like a lot of people who
are from here
see a different america that you and i
see how did america get here
i'd begin by saying that the immigrant
has a different perspective
by virtue of being an immigrant so we've
grown up in other cultures
and what that means is that when we come
to america we use a kind of
comparative standard we compare america
to the country we came from
and we realized that america is very
different in some ways quite unique
uh it offers possibilities to the
ordinary guy
that other countries even countries of
europe simply don't offer and not to the
same degree
and so we are excited by this it it
makes
our journey and the hardships that are
involved in making that journey
worthwhile
even though we have to sort of start
again start from scratch
um but what we don't realize is that we
have come into an america
that is divided and that native-born
americans
have big arguments about america itself
now their arguments are more insular
because
most of these americans have never lived
elsewhere they have
no basis of comparison they have no
other country to
uh to measure america against and so
what do they do
they come up with what i call the
utopian standard
so the utopian standard is a world for
example in which
no one has any prejudice no one judges
anybody for any reason
everybody has not only equal rights
under the law but the same
opportunities to succeed in life now
most people in the world would laugh if
you said these things because they know
that life is not like that we are all
dealt a deck of cards
in terms of intelligence and strength
and speed and
looks and all kinds of things and we
accept that as the given of life but
the one of the peculiarities of america
is that americans don't
they pretend that the world can be sort
of made anew
um and the argument inside of america is
something that immigrants are a little
startled by because
we find americans arguing about
questions that aren't even questions in
our mind at least not initially
and my own work has been caught up in
all this i
i think that my political views and my
perspective very much
shaped by the fact that i am an
immigrant i started out as an outsider
i've now of course lived most of my life
in america but
i viewed with great interest and
excitement
uh this internal debate in america about
america
so what uh what caused you to want to
write the uh to want to produce the
documentary
trump card i mean there seems to be a
you you seem like
i know you're in april baby my dad's an
april baby you seem very
systematic in your approach 2012 2014
2016 2018 2020 and it's typically
election year where you come out with a
documentary it's been going on every two
years
and then your big ones come out during
election year of presidency
but why uh go from the title of death of
a nation
uh or hillary's america in 2016 to now
trump card
uh to to call the documentary or trump
card and have it be around trump
yeah it was a decision i had to think
about because i have an accompanying
book that is out now called
united states of socialism and that was
the initial kind of working title
for the movie uh i think if bernie
sanders had been the democratic
candidate it would be a natural title
for the film
when biden got the nomination i began to
rethink a little bit
now i consider biden to be a creeping
socialist
whereas bernie is kind of an explicit
socialist so biden is moving in the
socialist direction it's no secret that
he's embraced many of the positions of
bernie
but there are some americans who don't
see him that way so i didn't want to
make a film where i say united states of
socialism people go what the heck you
you know bob biden's not a socialist i
also realize that the guy who defines
the political debate by the way not just
in america but in the world
is trump there's something about trump
that animates people one way or the
other
you know in in the play julius caesar
shakespeare writes that
caesar was the kind of colossus who
almost stands astride the entire world
it's all about him
it's all about caesar and i think right
now it's all about trump
uh and so trumpcard in that sense i
think jumps right
kind of with both feet into the middle
of the debate and that's why we call the
documentary trump card
i love the cover by the way your picture
on the cover is great but when i was
watching it i'm like
you know i think this was produced
with the thoughts of sanders was going
to be the nominee not biden
because i love the way this uh uh the
the
the the flow of stories on how you went
about it
uh from the original stories to bernie
sanders
honeymoon in moscow and explaining the
gentleman who was latino with
conservatives
the angles you took it was very very
interesting
and you know the the some of the
characters you brought obviously very
very controversial character the
gentleman that
told his story with barack obama's
experience back in the days
that got a few people killed and some
say that's the biggest conspiracy theory
where they don't even give it any
credence some say
it is but again i like the way you were
going about the storytelling
but would you say today because the one
question i always want to ask people who
are
in your world and this is what they do
for a living they have to you know they
study the topic of
uh politics economy news what's taking
place
what is our number one enemy today
meaning
if i am an immigrant i came to america
based on an idea that i saw in movies
and what i
read in books that you come to america
you can have any religion you want you
can't be controlled
i can start a business i can be a
millionaire a billionaire or just a guy
that just had a regular job and runs a
small liquor shop making 80 grand a year
and i
get to do whatever i want to do but i
control then i can have opinions i don't
like the president i like the president
and he got a bunch of these amendments
that we signed up for that brought us to
america
what is the biggest threat to america
today
the biggest threat to america today in
my opinion is
the uh domestic loss of confidence
in the idea of america and in the
american dream
because to me the american dream and
what that
um reflects what it represents is the
core of america
so a dream is really about the future a
dream is about
a better life for me later than i have
now
a better life for my children than i had
and that is this american
sense of things getting better and the
second part of that is
it includes a dream of responsibility
because who's going to make it better
you are you're going to be the architect
of your own future and that is an
exciting idea
but for some people it's a little bit of
a scary idea the notion that you're
in the driver's seat of your own life
now
when america was founded uh there was
uh slavery had been going on on this
continent for 150 years
uh we forget this because it all seems
like it's all in the past
but the founding was in 1776 and the
british had introduced slavery in the
americas
more than a hundred years earlier so
this is what the american founders
were confronted with that slavery was
embedded into society
it had been supported by the british
crown what do you do about it
how do you create a union when you have
uh
states that are meeting in philadelphia
and slavery is legal in all of them
so the american founders realize if we
decide in advance no slavery well
no one's gonna join no state will will
join the union so the american founders
decided look
let's create a union that is
anti-slavery in principle
but that tolerates slavery for a time
until we can build the political support
to overthrow it
that's the american founding that was
the architecture of the american
founding but
the view i'm giving you now is not the
mainstream view the mainstream view in
the universities that's taught in the
schools that comes from the left
is that slavery was the poison
that has destroyed the american dream
why
because we've never gotten over it that
slavery and the idea of racism that is
kind of the cousin of slavery
continues to be uh invisibly present
inside of every aspect of american life
so this is kind of why
the george floyd killing was so
um created such an uproar why because
nobody
you know people didn't look at it and
they could have looked at it and said
listen the lesson of the george floyd
killing is that we have a bad
cop now maybe there are other bad cops
and we got to go find them and get rid
of them
but of course the solution to bad cops
is naturally good cops
but you notice that the left didn't go
there they went in a completely
different direction namely
defund the cops you know so the
assumption of that is that all cops are
bad
now how can all cops be bad uh the
answer is because american society has
this built-in racism that somehow
almost like a virus infects all cops
um and so this larger narrative i think
if it is widely believed by the american
people
creates an internal demoralization a
loss of confidence if you will
i mean think about why the soviet union
collapsed it didn't actually collapse
because
it was attacked it was not blown up it
was it collapsed because it lost its
morale
it lost its reason for being same with
south africa by the way
south africa had this apartheid
structure in the 1980s
it collapsed because the south africans
themselves the white south africans
couldn't believe in it anymore
uh and i fear that that is a fate that
may one day
await america but not if not if i have a
say about it
so so let's talk about that so socialism
here's here's a question i got for you i
don't know what angle you'll take with
this one here is
you know one has to believe that even
the people today that are running
who are campaigning based on some
socialistic ideology or philosophies
these are not dumb people they know
socialism doesn't work i mean it's not
like even the people that are supporting
socialistic
ideology no it doesn't work which means
if you're sitting there and saying i'm
running to become a president my name is
joe biden
i think bernie sanders wants socialism i
think he thinks it's what
it works but i'm not talking about
sanders i'm talking about
a biden i'm talking about when hillary
ran i'm talking about
you know elizabeth warren some of these
folks
know this thing doesn't work aoc she's
team sanders fine let's set her aside
with sanders
if they know it doesn't work and they
know that could be one of the biggest
threats to america long term
what is the motive to get behind it is
it just to get their names in the
history books to say
check i became a president is it because
somebody behind closed doors has
threatened them that if you don't go
behind this campaign or
else is it because a soros is trying to
lead to an agenda to turn this into a
communistic or socialistic nation
what i'm trying to find out is they know
this doesn't work
what is the true motive to want to lead
american to socialistic ideology
the true motive is that um
they are a kind of person
that um well let me put it slightly
differently
america is divided into two kinds of
talented people
um the entrepreneurial type is the type
that makes things
uh entrepreneurs by and large create
things they build things they
they make something new but there's a
second type of person
uh this person is best represented by
the university professor but
it's a broader type lawyers are a lot
like this clergymen are like this
journalists are like this
these are kind of people of words you
and i are people of words
now we don't actually now we do create
products i create books i create movies
which is a celluloid
product but by and large i live in the
world of words
okay um academics and people who live in
the world of words academics and
journalists often think
that they are the truly smart people
they are the most
important people in the society and if
they look at a guy for example who owns
a franchise of let's say
10 mcdonald's or runs a pest control
business
they consider that guy their social and
cultural inferior
and yet in a capitalist society in a
free market society it may well be the
case
that a professor of romance languages
that say princeton
earns 150 000 a year
whereas a guy who never finished college
and is running a pest control business
is pulling in 500 000. so the professor
thinks
this is outrageous this is in fact an
assault on merit
people like me are smarter and we should
be actually running the society so this
is the kind of person who is attracted
to socialism not because
they're attracted to the full ideology
it's not that they embrace the full
marxist doctrine of it they just realize
that in a planned society
which has year plans which has the
government running things
people like them will be in charge
so elizabeth warren for example thinks
that she could run the banks
better than the banks can run the banks
it's simply not true
bernie sanders honestly thinks that he
can run the energy industry
better than all the guys in texas who
dig holes in the ground
those are guys who get their fingers
dirty um they
are familiar with technology they know
how to get oil out of the ground bernie
sanders has absolutely no idea i don't
even think he knows what fracking is
but somehow he thinks that i'm a smart
guy it can't be that hard
uh and wouldn't it be better instead of
having all these wildcatters running
around
digging out oil in the ground and
hurting the environment doing whatever
they want
wouldn't it be good to have a rational
planning process that governs
all of that so these guys in that sense
it is the combination of the attraction
of power and the honest belief
that people like them are better at
running this society
than the people who are running it now
yeah but that still doesn't answer my
question what i'm what i'm trying to
find
out is let's let's focus on a biden and
let's focus on
obama okay when obama first got elected
the threat was oh this guy may be a
communist you guys got to be careful
because
you know his uh father when he wrote the
book about his father and you know
mother and the influence that he had in
his life growing up and van jones when
he was first van jones used to be linked
to a comment
oh my gosh this guy may be a communist i
don't want to go any guy got elected
okay i mean he did some stuff but obama
wasn't as scary as people thought he was
going to be
right i would say even as somebody
that's fiscally
conservative registered independent
people thought he was going to be
a a lot a lot of people were worried
about what he was going to do
fundamentally changing things now you
got a sanders he is
fully fundamentally on a complete
opposite side
aoc fully on a whole different side like
bernie sanders probably doesn't think
that
obama did enough like he should have
done this and he should have done that
and secretly he probably feels
disappointed with the amount of uh
social programs that obama came up with
or didn't come up with right
what i'm trying to what i'm asking here
is the following i'm trying to find out
for myself and maybe this is a selfish
question i'm asking
the world knows socialism doesn't work
the world knows communism doesn't work
the world knows you can't
show a product that was developed from
that system
even all these countries like russia and
china eventually said dude we got to get
to this capitalism system to
get people to own businesses and have
identity and all this other stuff
what is the motive to get the only
country left in the world that's the
leading country
in the philosophy of capitalism if this
thing goes
a lot are going to follow why why would
you
drive the initiative of socialism
knowing that doesn't work what is the
motive behind that
it's got to be more than the professor's
thinking the fact that the plumber's
making 500
000 without a degree it's got to be
bigger than that what's the motive
it operates on many levels that that's
just one level here's another level
you've got all these young people
and they are uh they are actually living
in the middle of technological
capitalism
but they're a little bit like the fish
that is not really conscious of the
water
because the water is all around them so
their world includes
uber and iphones and
airbnb and gps now none of this would
have come without technological
capitalism right
if you had left it up to the post office
for example they probably wouldn't even
have thought of overnight mail
it took outside age private companies
like ups and fedex
and then then the post office goes oh
wow you know even though the airplane's
been around for 100 years
you know we can still do that we can do
it now so they got
but no innovation comes out of
government per se or very little
um but for a lot of young people they
take all this for granted they never
think about
how did they how did all these things
come to be they didn't magically fall
out of the sky
what is the system that produced them
they don't think about that
rather what they think about is simply
this they they have and i think their
professors are very complicit in this
have inculcated in them the honest
belief
that capitalism is unjust and in
fairness i have to say
that the defenders of capitalism don't
do a good job
in explaining why it is just not just
why it is efficient
just so for example if a guy makes
something
uh let's just say let's just take me as
an author for example now if i write a
book
and i publish it and it happens to be
during the great depression
and nobody buys the book the book is
let's say a failure
and then 10 years later the economy
recovers and is doing better and i issue
the same book and it's a massive success
think about it's the same book in terms
of the merit of it
i've released the same product but in
one environment it's unsuccessful
in another environment i'm a millionaire
so the ordinary guy looking at that goes
well how can a system be just
when the same product in two different
environments produces a completely
different outcome so
this what happens is young people are
raised to believe that there's something
completely arbitrary
about the rewards of capitalism and
therefore they become vulnerable to the
argument hey
why don't we have a different
organization maybe socialism in the old
sense doesn't work
but it is partly you know the american
optimism that says we can find a way
that's going to make it work
we're going to find a way that will
leave all the problems of the past
behind and so for example one common
thing you hear
politicians say is we don't want
authoritarian socialism you know we
don't want the socialism of mao
and lenin and stalin we're not going
there we want
democratic socialism and so if you
listen to aoc
or bernie sanders they almost never use
the word socialism without the adjective
democratic yes why because they believe
that democracy
this idea of popular consent gives more
legitimacy
to the idea of socialism so they're
trying to create in in fairness they're
trying to create something of a new type
of socialism
that hasn't existed before the only
question is when something has been
tried not once or twice
but 25 times across virtually
two-thirds of the world and failed every
single time
what makes you think it's going to
succeed now well so okay so
socialism capitalism if america becomes
socialistic who wins who loses well
everybody loses in the end because a
socialist society is a society of misery
and tyranny
um the this seems a little hard for
americans to believe
my wife is from venezuela and so she
talks about
how in venezuela today if you walk into
grocery stores and this has been true
now for almost 20 years
the grocery store is completely empty uh
all it has is like a hundred bottles of
ketchup
empty shelves uh so even if you have
money you can't buy anything
now if i were to say this to americans
they they give me a funny look like this
is
this is ridiculous this is hard to
believe but interestingly under
coronavirus we just got a little
small preview on a temporary basis
of what socialism would look like on a
permanent basis
and the other thing we saw in the
coronavirus was a kind of this is the
beginning
of an attack on civil liberties and by
that i mean things like
we're going to have drones monitoring
your movements
if you don't wear a mask we want your
neighbors to kind of call in on you
i mean think about this is these are the
staple moves of a socialist country
you know report on your parents uh and
you'd never think you'd see this in
america but we've seen little glimmers
of it in america
in the last several months yeah and
you're seeing uh
the exit is taking place right now with
elon musk saying listen i'm gonna move
my tesla corporation and
build the trucks and all these other
things out of austin
and even a podcaster like rogan said i'm
just leaving austin myself as well i'm
not going to stay here i'm going to go
out there and
you know whatever part of texas that
rogan's going to be moving to but he's
leaving california
because they're both extremely
frustrated what's going on with
california
you know the the concept of capitalism
is two things becomes the enemy
the few protected by the majority
minority protected by the few
so if you're part of the few that's
creating the jobs and you're very
wealthy and you've done very well you
can be bullied by the majority
how are the few protected by the
majority i guess the question i'm trying
to ask is the following so
in a sales organization and a company
that expands
sometimes companies that are in sales
they flatten out because they want to
recognize
everybody because they're afraid of
losing sales people so for example
imagine i'm running a real estate
company i got a 100
realtors i have to say well you know
johnny's also doing good bobby's also
doing good great job larry great job
jackie great job mary
and competition goes away so then the
guy that's killing it he's doing 20 50
of the production he said i'm going
somewhere else because i need the proper
recognition
but sometimes the 82 agents who are not
the top producers complaining about the
one guy can drive the one guy
away to say i can't be here you guys are
not realizing i'm here six a.m i'm
leaving nine i'm working on the weekends
you guys are not
you're bringing in two deals a month i'm
bringing in 10 deals a month how can i
be protected here
my question for you is this the few who
are willing to work their tails off and
create jobs and constantly innovate and
take this to the next level
how are they protected by the majority
in america
so they aren't and i think you've now
touched on maybe the heart of the
problem
and it applies by the way way beyond the
economy it applies in politics it
applies in in every high school
when i was in school uh we had in in
this was in india i was in high school
in india i went to college in the united
states
we had a system of ranking which
literally meant that
in my class which had 50 students in it
they would give you grades and they
would tell you who's first in class and
who's second and third
all the way to fifty so the dumbest guy
in class knew that he was the dumbest
because he was number fifty
right did everybody dates like that i
think still today it's like that
now uh the point i wanna make is this
naturally a system like this produces
discontent
among all the people who are at the
bottom and if a teacher were to come
along and say listen i want to abolish
this ranking system
i in fact i don't want to have any
grades at all everybody's going to get
the same grade
all the people who are in the middle and
the bottom are in support of that system
because it benefits them it does not
benefit the people who work hard and get
better ranks and grades because their
achievement is devalued and so
here's the question to ask which group
is bigger
the people at the top who are doing well
or the larger number
who would much rather pull the standard
down and the answer is the larger number
it's always bigger
now in a school which is run by let's
just say an
enlightened group of of educators
they're going to say listen
we need to keep some form of a ranking
system we may not
have necessarily exact ranks but we need
grades we need certain forms of
distinction
so people are motivated to work hard
same with the corporation
in a profit-making company the ceo is
going to say i don't care
if jill and tom and dick and harry
feel demoralized i need to encourage
salesmen who are going to actually make
the sale
i need to create an environment where
everyone has a chance
but the people who succeed are
recognized now here's the point in
politics however
it's the opposite you were asking
earlier about people like biden so it's
dawned upon people like biden and people
like elizabeth warren
that the people who truly create wealth
is a small group in society whereas the
people who actually want more of that
wealth that would rather see the wealth
spread around
is a larger group in society so if
to put it differently the the writer
bernard shaw once said any government
that robs peter to pay paul
can always count on paul's vote and so
interestingly our politicians have
figured out you take an
elon musk what if i were to say let's
just take away half of his money
and give it to 10 000 people who will
then be the beneficiaries of that
obviously there's one guy who's going to
be opposed elon musk
and they're going to be 10 000 people
who go yeah give it give it
that's a more just system i vote for
that so in
although this is a very crude example in
some ways it captures the heart
of what democratic socialism is all
about it's all about confiscating
from the wealth creators and giving to
people who are
not as well off not because they're
needy not because of social justice
but because that's how you get their
political support
so what can the few do to be protected
by the majority
the few incredibly have only one defense
in a democratic society
i mean from the founders point of view
there's a constitutional defense
so the constitution was set up so that
the majority cannot raid the few
but the problem is that even our
constitution is open to interpretation
and so our constitution has not proved
as strong a barrier
to people confiscating wealth in this
way so the bottom line is the few can
only do one thing they
have to convince the many that
this is not a good thing so in other
words the few have got to convince the
american people
that a mass ripoff of the few it will
ultimately hurt the many also
yeah so not easy to do yeah not easy to
do because
the many have an immediate gain by
rating the few
and the few have to make an argument
that's kind of a long-term argument
that listen if you come and rob my house
i'm not going to want to make new stuff
and there aren't going to be new
innovations and new products and
ultimately you will suffer
uh but the many if you're short-sighted
are not going to look at that and go
wait a minute i'd like to get the free
stuff in the beginning i'll worry about
the other problem later
that's that's a tough argument to win
for the few though
because the the few have to you have to
realize the majority are not
turned on by the words of responsibility
accountability
you know you have the choice to change
your life and make it better
that's unattractive to a big community
you know the the
you know i have i was having a
conversation with one of our guys
yesterday and we're having lunch
and this guy's in real estate and he
tells me about one of the guys
who he worked with whom i've known for
20 years
and i've watched this guy one of the
most talented guys i've ever seen in my
life and he was a talented bunch of the
friends maybe even more talent than
everybody and then everybody
but he always used the challenges he
faced in his life with his mom with his
dad with his family with his girlfriend
with his wife with everybody on why he's
not winning it was always an element of
blaming somebody else
and what was a very proven tactic was
constantly crying
and getting people to feel guilty for
him feel bad for him
and it was a mechanism to say man that's
why i feel so bad for him
i feel so bad for him i feel so bad for
him and most people don't have a
rebuttal to that i don't know what to
say i don't know
and then i just sat down with this guy
and i said listen man you fooled people
your entire life how difficult your
life's been i just have to tell you man
your life has not has been as difficult
as that guy as this guy's as that how
come they're winning and we're all
friends
how can you say that what can i say no i
say i just think you're
finding in out to validate why you're
not willing to be held accountable work
hard and be responsible that's a lot of
pressure on you you want to be able to
have an out
and you don't like that kind of stuff
and that friction of just dealing direct
you know he doesn't like that kind of a
conversation i don't think
uh i think there's a community that
doesn't want somebody to say
it's your fault i don't i don't think
there's a community that wants to say
why don't you do something about it why
don't you pick up a book and read about
it
so again i'm thinking long term i'm
thinking if you're creating an
environment
of wanting to develop disciplined people
what are you going to do you're always
going to have a community that's going
to say it's not fair you're making too
much money you're doing this you're
doing that
how does the few get protected by these
guys by the way going back to the indian
system
uh india system of one to fifty how how
did it work out are they still doing it
and if it is
what was the energy was everybody like
oh my gosh i'm ranked 29th
i'm gonna try to beat this guy on b27
what was it like did they work better
together
did they not work together was it more
individualistic
did people team up together to do
homework together to me in the top five
how did that dynamic work well when i
was in school
you know like any system it had mixed
effects it's true that there were some
people at the very bottom and they're
like i don't care
you know in other words many of them
would say i don't care about school
i want to i just come to school to play
marbles in recess or i come to school to
play cricket
i don't care about academics etc uh i
when i was um young i was typically in
the group that was fifth or sixth in
class
um so i was a smart kid but i wasn't
that smart i wasn't at the top of my
class
and i remember i once went to my dad and
i said you know look at these guys who
are
who are one two and three i said are
they a lot smarter than me because i i
don't seem to i'm not even close to
being able to catch them
and my dad goes well you know son they
they actually work a lot harder than you
do
and i go well you know i study for an
hour or two a day after school
he goes that's it he goes they study for
four to five hours a day
after school after school in addition to
school and i was
initially i thought my dad was joking
and so i talked to these guys who were
my friends and i kind of
kind of asked them these questions and i
realized my dad was right
they worked twice as hard as i did so
this
motivated me and i go okay that's it you
know i'm going to improve my study
habits this is ridiculous
um so i began to compete so i know in my
own case
my psychology was such that having a
system that was competitive
not competitive in a mean-spirited way
just competitive in the sense that they
they take all your grades and all your
your school marks as they call them and
they add them up
so there's no there's no subjectivity in
it either your first or your second or
your third
this is simply a math kind of a math
phenomenon and i be and i realized i had
to work harder and immediately i began
to see my scores improve
and and being able to come to america
was the result of that effort
i would not have been chosen as an
exchange student to come to america if i
didn't if i wasn't motivated
to pull myself up into the top ranks of
my class
that helped me get the scholarship to
get to america which helped me to go to
an ivy league college
and help build my career so my point is
the motivation to succeed i think is
very important and we don't want to lose
that in america
in the name of sort of coddling the
self-esteem of everybody
is that how the system's always been in
india or is that a recent thing
no i think it's been that way for a long
time now under the british when india
was a colony of the british
the british had a meritocratic system
for the indians but it had a sort of a
you could call it the colonial ceiling
you know we talk about the glass ceiling
so an indian could rise but only so far
you could be a civil servant but you
can't rise above a certain level
and this is actually what created a lot
of discontent a lot of the indian
independence leaders
came out of that they hit that ceiling
and they were like ouch
and then they realized listen we have to
create a different society so the
british in a way were really stupid
because had they created a system where
the indians could keep rising
this would have allowed the indian
independence leaders themselves to rise
within the british system
one of those leaders wrote a book years
and years ago called the unbritishness
of british rule in india
and his argument was that the british
are not applying their own principles
of merit and freedom and openness and
opportunity they're not letting the
indians if you will have a piece of the
pie
and he was saying that that's all we're
asking the british to do
be more british allow us to have some of
the same opportunities you make
available
to your own countrymen but the british
wouldn't do it
and i think this is part of the reason
they got kicked out by the way that's
just fascinating period i know it has
nothing to do with your documentary or
what the work you do
is no wonder india is producing some of
the best engineers around the world
on at iit and 40 000 kids apply and
barely any of them get into the school
it's such a competitive environment
i was there a couple years ago i spoke
at iit with the arundati bacharia and
divyang turaki a bunch of these other
uh billionaires and i had a great time i
just i got tours i went to the slums i
went all over the place
and the one spirit i did feel was a lot
of competition
and anytime i feel a spirit of
competition you just know the future
looks bright if there's a lot of
competition
because innovation is going to be taking
place uh thank you for sharing that with
us
you know the one thing you mentioned
your wife being venezuelan
and you know in the documentary i
believe
you and her were speaking to one of the
best uh marksmen that we have and she
was
incredible at the way uh uh at what she
was doing
they were telling a story about how hugo
chavez and venezuela had a tv show
i still can't believe that tv show did
he really have a tv show where he would
go around in the city
cameras following him he would take
apartments away in homes away and give
it to poor people
is that really a tv show that he had yes
the the theme that we develop in the
movie is we show the parallels between
venezuelan socialism
and some of the approaches to socialism
that the left is pursuing in america
and one of those of course is to
demonize the rich
uh and to expropriate expropriate simply
means to confiscate to take away
the possessions of the rich now in
america we proposed to do this elizabeth
warren bernie sanders they proposed to
do this through confiscatory taxation so
very high tax rates and unbelievably you
have people in america talking about tax
rates of 70 75
which think about it means you make a
dollar you keep 25 cents and you give
them the rest
and that's only federal taxation now in
venezuela it's a little bit more blunt
or blatant
and so ugo chavez who um now dead but
ugh is the former dictator he's now
succeeded by his vice president maduro
ugo chavez had a television show called
hello presidente
uh hello mr president and you'd see him
walking down the street
and he'd have a bunch of aids with him
and he'd say listen you know take a look
at that story
who owns that one and the aides would go
oh you know that's that's some jews they
they own it he goes okay expropriate it
and literally his guys would go in the
store and throw the people out
right then right there uh and then he'd
say what about that store who owns that
who owns that business and they'd say
well
that's one of your political opponents
expropriate it
so they go in there throw the people out
so this kind of thing
is in a way you could almost call it the
the true face of socialism
uh now no one in america will want to do
it this way why because it looks bad
um if you have democratic socialism
you've got to convince the people that
you are on the site
on the side of truth and justice and the
american way so if you do any bad stuff
you've got to do it behind closed doors
um but it's the same thing it's
expropriating the hard-earned money and
wealth of other people
it represents their blood sweat and
tears abraham lincoln by the way put it
beautifully 150 years ago he summarized
it this way
you work and i eat and he was actually
talking about slavery
and lincoln said that the essence of
slavery is it's theft
one guy does the work and another guy
steals the product of his labor
but what lincoln might have been very
disheartened to realize is
it's still going on
you know uh uh the i have a big
community of
venezuela's in the company i was trying
to reach out to maduro to do an
interview with him
and you know was very technical i
believe his
opponent the president i always have a
hard time pronouncing this name gaido
uh gaido that i said right yeah he
agreed and we were trying to orchestrate
a meeting together
but uh the part that
you know concerns me is here's a bunch
of venezuelans
who left venezuela who
don't believe in what maduro and hugo
chavez did
these are regular people that wanted to
have a better career they love their
country they love their land
but they come here and they're
supporting
many of the same candidates who have
similar belief system
as they did there now i'm not saying
everybody you you and i both know it's
not everybody
yes for every 100 story i got 20 stories
of people that say i just want business
i want
i'm at this i know all those stories but
the majority of them
even though they escaped socialism even
though they escaped
the motto that they had they still
somehow are loyal to it why do you think
that is
i think that the majority of venezuelans
probably
see the light in other words they
recognize they recognize the signs
of socialism here they it looks all too
familiar to them
and they immediately rebel against it
but you are quite right
that there are some including some
powerful um
venezuelans who don't see it at all
now part of the reason they don't see it
is they are making the
wrong type of comparison to let's give
you an idea
there have been riots that have been
going on in several american cities
right now uh people setting
fire to the federal building in portland
and so what does the government do well
first of all the us government is in its
usual fashion
extremely tolerant of all this if you
try to do this in india
you would get shot i mean there's no
question that by this time they would
have called out the military and people
would be getting shot so very few
countries will put up with this but now
but in america you do
so the police are basically shooting
pepper and putting in you know
a tear gas spray but they're not harming
the rioters they're letting the riders
do what they do
um but from the optical point of view
what do you see and
let's say you're a venezuelan in america
you see a
country in which the regime the
government is unleashing the cops
uh on these protesters now the
protesters are left-wingers many of them
are socialists
but if you are to ask yourself which is
you know which is the government and
which is the protesters
they identify with the protesters
because they think oh wow
in venezuela the people who are
protesting the regime
are the anti-socialists they don't
realize that in america
you know the situation is flipped that
what's really going on is that the
socialists are the ones doing writing
they're breaking the law
and they're not breaking the law because
anybody's oppressing them no one's done
anything to them
it's not like in it's not like in
venezuela where the regime is taking
their wealth taking their homes
confiscating their property
you know none of that's going on these
are people who want to create
some sort of revolutionary overthrow of
the system
uh we're trying to impose law and order
but for a venezuelan they could
basically say well look that's the
maduro regime that's the chavez regime
unleashing the cops and the protesters
so this is a i think a complete
misunderstanding of what's going on
and that's the downside of being an
immigrant sometimes when you're an
immigrant
and you haven't been here long enough
and you haven't paid close attention
you're going to make a quick analogy
between what happened over there and
what happened over here
and suddenly you're going to say things
like oh you know the trump
administration are the mullahs you know
and so you haven't thought through the
ways in which america is a different
kind of society and protest
has a different meaning here yeah it's
going to be very interesting because uh
most of them that i know uh they're hard
workers they're good people
family oriented conservative beliefs you
know
they want the right values and
principles they just kind of want to be
left alone to go to work but i can't
comprehend how they don't see some of
the philosophies that some of these
politicians are having
by the way you'll hear the saying you
know we want scandinavian model of
socialism not necessarily what happened
with venezuela
what what are some things that we don't
know about the scandi
scandinavian socialistic philosophy
that i think will shock people once they
find out how the model really works
i think there are a couple of uh points
that need to be made here
because the scandinavian model is the
only socialism that you'd have to say to
some degree it does work
um i don't claim that the scandinavian
model
is a failure it works if you are willing
to accept
its strength and its weakness now its
strength
is that the scandinavians are capitalist
in creating wealth
although they are socialist and
distributing it so this is an important
distinction
because in creating wealth the
scandinavians are not socialists they
don't
like in in venezuela one of the first
things that maduro did
was he appointed socialist bureaucrats
to run the venezuelan oil company now
venezuela is the largest oil reserves in
the world more than saudi arabia
but it takes technical expertise to get
that oil out why
because it's in the orinoco oil belt
it's a certain type of thick oil
that has to be liquefied before you can
sell it in the world it takes a lot of
technical expertise is my point
uh chavez fired all the technical
experts and brings in like bernie
sanders types
you know to run the oil company well
needless to say he runs the oil company
into the ground
it hardly produces any oil anymore um
now the scandinavians don't do that
the scandinavians are a very
entrepreneurial society they encoura
look at all the scandinavian companies
that are doing well in the world
so they have low corporate taxes they
have no minimum wage
you can hire and fire people for any
reason they have less
regulation than in europe and in america
um
they don't have any of these um no no
inheritance tax
i think norway is the only scandinavian
country that has a wealth tax
so overall and the scandinavians do not
kill the goose that lays the golden eggs
now they do have a big welfare state
but they make everybody pay for it they
have what's called the vat tax that is
the value added tax
25 on consumption and remember that a
vat tax any economist will tell you
falls heavier on the middle class
and on the poor than it does on the rich
because middle class and poor people
spend more of their money more higher
explain that can you can you explain
that so so if i'm making four thousand
dollars a month versus
i'm making fifty thousand dollars a
month why does the vet
the uh tax the consumption tax hurt the
four thousand dollars a month
versus a fifty thousand dollar a month
person because if you're making four
thousand dollars a month you're going to
spend
probably two to three thousand dollars a
month on consumption items you needed to
live
uh and so as a result you're paying 25
of a tax on that now the rich guy is
probably spending more than you
but he's probably spending five to six
thousand dollars a month on consumption
so he's paying more in dollar terms but
proportionately he's paying a lot less
because he spends a smaller fraction of
his money on consumption that's why the
tax falls heavier
on their lower classes i think it's very
important for people to realize it
because even the scandinavian economist
explained that
in your documentary to say that you if
you if you decide to come here
yes it may be socialism but it hurts the
lower income people
more than it does to higher income
people because you're paying a
consumption tax
much higher than the others and that was
very good visual that was given there
for people to know the
math on how it works now the socialism
that sanders
and aoc are pitching and presenting
are they presenting a socialism of that
model and can it work in u.s if not
why not well it would work in the u.s
i think to a degree if you were honest
about it so for example
in scandinavia if you make sixty
thousand dollars
in norway or sweden you pay a fifty
percent tax rate
so it's really simple you make sixty
thousand dollars or seventy thousand
dollars
write a check for thirty five thousand
dollars and send it in now
no democratic politician in the united
states will stand up and say this
to the american people because they know
that the american people would have a
heart attack
if you were to tell them that they have
to send half their income straight off
the top
into federal taxes so what they do is
they have a different model i call it
the millionaires and billionaires model
they tell the american people we're
going to give you all these welfare
state benefits but here's the good news
you don't have to pay why because we're
going to catch these other guys these
millionaires and billionaires
and what's kind of funny about this too
by the way if you look at the early
bernie sanders
he always railed against millionaires
and billionaires
but then when he became a millionaire he
stopped
suddenly he only talks about
billionaires so if you listen to him now
he rarely says millionaires
why because he has three homes so any
millionaire program would apply to him
so what he's done is he's ratcheted it
up and so now he's giving the people the
illusion that
look i'll catch people like elon musk
i'll catch people like jeff bezos
i'll make them pay for your house i'll
make them pay for your college education
so ultimately this is not the
scandinavian model the scandinavian
model is don't demonize the rich
don't demonize us successful we are all
in the same
boat if we want to have welfare state
benefits the cost of that has got to be
distributed
over the whole society yeah
it would be very interesting now here's
a question for you
uh dinesh you got a family i i saw your
daughter in there i think you have
three kids one of your own a two-step
but you have three kids of your own
um the question i like to ask when we're
having lunch with our guys
is you know my family left iran we went
to germany if germany was so amazing we
wouldn't have come to america we would
have just stayed in germany because
germany's opportunity was great but my
family decided to bring us to america
what needs to happen in america
for you to say you know what i'm out
what needs to happen in america for you
to say i'm out and if it does get to
that point
where would you go to that would be a
second option to america
well um i don't know where i would go to
and i've probably come along enough in
life that i i wouldn't make the move
uh i would stay in america in part
because i think that
america would is still kind of worth
fighting for so even if america in my
view kind of went down
i would probably still stay on the ship
now
um and i would do it in pure gratitude
for what the country has just done for
my life
over most of my life i do
see an attack on the very principles
that i came to america to be part of so
in some sense there's an attack on that
america and um and i'm worried about
america because
the american dream is fragile it's
fragile in the sense that it
it relies upon people who believe in it
the founders said something
very interesting i think it might have
been uh ben franklin
uh or madison i don't remember now but
they said something the effect that that
the american republican form of
government
relies upon the moral character of the
people
and if that moral character is eroded or
lost
then the system doesn't really work now
by moral character here they're not
talking about religious views and
they're not talking about theological
beliefs
they're talking about things like the
work ethic they're talking about things
like the
the centrality of family and and the
family as an incubator of those human
values we learn more in the
in the educational institution called
the family than we learn even in school
so the founders thought that this
infrastructure
is really important for the country to
continue to be successful
that's what made america successful but
we have to keep those institutions to be
successful in the future
i think that the verdict is kind of up
in the air which is to say
i i wouldn't bet sort of one way or the
other uh but i continue
to have confidence and that america will
pull through
well so so just to push back a little
bit then what
my interpretation of what you're saying
is that all these documentaries that
make someone be afraid of what's going
on with america they shouldn't really be
that concerned
because even the executive producer a
person that's making all these
documentaries
doesn't think it's going to get that bad
where you would want to move your family
elsewhere is that a fair assessment
well the problem for moving is is
twofold one is i feel like a patriotic
obligation not to do that
but the second is i also don't know
where to go because
uh when you when you say that the term
american exceptionalism
refers to what's unique about america so
let's talk about what that is for a
minute
you know um when my mom um now dad but
when my mom was in her 70s she came to
visit america
we were driving um on the highway and
she saw a sign on the side of the road
adopt a highway and my mom looked at it
and she was like
what is that adopt a highway what are
they talking about and i go well you
know it's this program in america where
a private group
um the rotary club or some group can
adopt the highway and they agree to
clean the highway and kind of keep
maintain the highway
and my mom was like why would anyone do
that she couldn't understand why
anybody would think of adopting a
highway what nothing could be more
ridiculous to her than the concept
of adopting a so there's something in
the american character
that takes on this public obligation of
cleaning a street
a road uh and private individuals are
willing to devote time to do that that's
a very american thing you know or
if you take a typical american family
with three kids it's not surprising that
one guy
is um you know working as a engineer in
google
uh and another guy is selling real
estate and a third guy
is pumping gas at a gas station now
think about that
in india if you said that people would
give you a funny look like how strange
in the same family are you telling me
one guy is in the upper mobile class and
the other guy's pumping gas
but in america that's normal in america
it's normal for people's
fate to be completely different even
though they come from the same family
they're in the same
they've had the same upbringing and the
same socialization
um so in america you have
mobility people move up the ladder but
people also move down the ladder
and uh so all of these are the
distinctive characteristics of america
now you don't find them even in europe
i'm very familiar with europe
i'm very familiar with indians in europe
so an asian indian who's in london will
tell me things like you know i'm very
successful
but i can even but i'll always be a
pakistani
i'll always be an indian in london in
other words i can't actually become an
englishman
i mean i can say i am but i'm not going
to be i'm not going to feel
100 british but i feel 100
american and that tells me that america
allows the outsider
a full membership which other countries
don't offer
in other words it's difficult for a turk
to become a german for an algerian to
become a frenchman
for a pakistani to become an englishman
uh and again that's that's something
unique about america so if we lose that
where am i going to go
and become a full member of that club i
can't do that in new zealand i'm
tempted to go some to some far away
place but i don't know what faraway
place would would
recreate if you will what i came to
america to experience
is there any possibility that america
can lose all of those things that you
just talked about
i think that that possibility is low but
it is not
um it is not zero um and
what that means is that that's you know
you were mentioning the documentaries i
make the films
in order to to fight the trend i make
the films in order to educate people
uh for most of my career i was a writer
and a speaker
and then i realized i'm reaching a
fairly large circle my books are selling
well or best sellers and so on but
i'm only reaching a certain type of
person
uh when i make a movie i stand in the
back of the theater and i see all kinds
of guys in there whom i would never see
like waiting to
buy a book in barnes noble so the
the beauty of movies is that they uh
reach a wider audience but also
a movie appeals to the head and the
heart uh when you said earlier that you
know that i tell these stories
that's what a movie is a movie is a
narrative which
tells stories that help people not only
to understand
but also to see for themselves uh what
the world is like and what the world can
be like
yeah but what i'm saying is if if a
hillary clinton would have been
elected in 2016 instead of a trump
it's fair to say you wouldn't been
pardoned and for that
twenty thousand dollar thing that you
were arrested for and you got a felony
for and they have it on your wikipedia
which
many others have done and no no one's
ever gotten arrested and gotten a felony
for
you'll probably still be doing time
which means the next time around that
a person who is against trump's camp is
elected you're probably going back to
prison
so so the and again i'm i'm just saying
i'm only saying this to say then that
makes other people who are wanting to be
vocal about making content and
documentaries to say i don't want to go
to prison
i'm okay let somebody else like the next
take the responsibility and if he's
willing to go do time forward more power
to him i don't want to do it i'm going
to be okay
living my regular life so it's a form of
shutting people up so
you know maybe the question will be a
different kind of a question to ask you
say dinesh is not the millionaire today
say dinesh hasn't produced
many different documentaries three of
them which have done
10 million plus dollars which if i'm a
business guy looking at your stuff
the only one that broke even is death of
a nation everything outside of that
you're bringing back a minimum of 150
percent to
uh 1200 percent return on money so
somebody gives you a hundred thousand
dollars for the documentary
i'm making somewhere between 250 000
to 1.5 million dollars if you come to me
as an investor to invest into your
documentary you kind of know what you're
doing
only one of them broke even right that's
your history three out of four have been
profitable
so if you're not today's dinesh
if you're the 32 year old dinesh with 28
in your checking account i don't know
what you had at 30 times just kind of
put things into
uh numbers out there if you're the 32
you're trying to find your way you
haven't yet broken
the mold people don't yet know you
you're working very hard
you got some money here and there but
less than a hundred thousand dollars
and if if crap were to hit the fan
would you consider if all the basic
values that brought me and you here
would you consider
leaving and looking at other options
well i would i would think twice about
um
going into um making these kinds of
documentaries because they
strike directly at very powerful people
and um and i probably didn't realize
when i did the obama documentary
that i was you know taking on the most
powerful man in the world i mean i knew
it
in the abstract but i didn't know what
the ramifications of it
are and by that i mean i'm not even just
talking about obama but somebody for
example could be sitting in the justice
department this would be the holder
justice department and go
you know that guy just made a film that
bashes the boss
why don't we start looking at his tax
returns why don't we see if we can get
his bank statements and see if we can
find something in there that he did
that we can go after him for let's teach
him a lesson and the lesson is exactly
not even for him because he probably
will get a good lawyer he'll probably be
able to figure out a way
the lesson is for all the young dinesh's
out there to send none the message
so the important thing here is this by
the way
i know i've always known that if you
make this kind of a film in india
you will get your legs broken okay so if
i were to make a film about the most
powerful man in india
uh i would have to be very careful to
make sure that goons wouldn't come to my
house and and
break my legs if not kill me um but
um many people have the belief and i did
too that that won't happen in america
that in america you can take on the most
powerful guy
and you can say whatever you want and
you can say it in the public square
and there's free speech in this country
and sure if you did something wrong the
government will go after you
but you're going to get the same penalty
as anyone else who did the same thing so
let's just say for example you're
speeding on the highway
yes you're going to get a fine but it's
not fair they try to put you in jail for
two years
because you exceeded the speed limit
that's not equal justice under the law
and that's kind of my complaint about my
case is not that i did exceed the
campaign finance law but i didn't get a
penalty that is commensurate with what i
did with what other people have gotten
for doing that
so that's the point is it's been
disheartening to see that
in at least in the political sphere
equal justice under the law sometimes
gets pushed aside
uh and fighting to restore that is to me
one of the
greatest priorities that we have now so
you don't have another country like you
wouldn't say singapore or panama or
anything else you've not done the
investigation to know if there was a
second or third option for america like
you know how
time magazine does a article in 2012
and it's a united states of texas i
think it's a title of the arctic i don't
remember the exact title maybe united
states of texas
and it shows the fact that uh for every
two people that go to texas from
california
one comes from texas to cal uh
california you know
two go from california texas one come
from texas to california they're showing
all this data
and why people are leaving california
okay so then
that led to a lot of other lists here's
the top stage to be in usa today there's
an article the war state on american
taxes is california 50
50th place 42nd is new york best is
tennessee
florida ranks here texas is eight and
you're seeing all these lists well a
business owner is going to sit there and
say
why am i going to stay in california pay
the 13.3 or the 15 on pain over here i'm
going to go to texas i'm going to go to
florida
i'm going to go to a different place i
think the part where we're getting close
to
is competition creates opportunity
and if competition creates opportunity i
do think the days of students come into
america and taking
classes and getting a degree and the
days of wanting to stay and not leave
have gone to let me take what i learned
here back to my country it's no longer
oh my gosh
let me stay here a lot of people around
the world are concerned about if america
is going to stay the same or not
because they're just watching a level of
division it's typically us
watching other countries being divided
but today it's other countries watching
america saying what the hell is going on
over there with the level of division
that's why i ask you the question
what would be some of the other
alternatives if america if the idea of
america didn't work
where would someone go to well it's a
completely
um different question to ask me um you
know when i have
uh i'm now in my 50s i've got family
here as to put the same question to sort
of 17 year old dinesh you know so if i
was
if i go back to when i first came to
america and there are a lot of indians
who are in that position now and as you
say
a much larger percentage of them go back
why well partly because
india got rid of socialism india moved
away from socialism
india today is is one of the most
pro-american countries in the world
um you talk to an ordinary indian on the
street what do they
like about the world they like america
they like what america stands for
they're trying to bring that to india
india is trying to have the american
dream not the indian dream there's no
indian dream
but the american dream so a lot of
indians feel that in this atmosphere
where i have my own culture my own
cuisine
of chicken tikka masala my family my
neighbors
why would i make that journey and go
someplace else i'd rather
get educated there if i have to but i'll
i'll come back home so i understand and
respect that choice
my brother works for a shipping company
that's based in singapore
it's a nice life in singapore uh if you
want to be
you know follow the law and be anonymous
and have a prosperous life and have
nobody interfere with you
now political dissent is a little
problematic but if you stay out of
politics and do your own thing
you can have a nice life in singapore no
doubt about it
um but uh it's not a choice for me
but the very fact that we're having this
kind of discussion is kind of telling i
don't think we would have had this
discussion 25 years ago
because there would be no such debate we
would we would recognize that america
is is unique and does certain things and
we'd recognize that if we want those
things there's no better place to be
than america
but the very fact that we're questioning
it now suggests to me that we have seen
some erosion of that american dream
it'd be interesting for a state in
america to say look you guys are going a
direction we don't want to go to we're
just going to distance ourselves and
you know be our own country and uh you
know
for example a state like texas to say
we're just kind of going to do our thing
we don't know what the hell you guys are
thinking about let us separate
before things get a little bit weirder
here but uh yeah i think people i think
people are starting to ask
options about alternatives today and i
think it's a very important thing for
everybody on the left and the right to
realize that some people are going to
consider leaving and some of them are
going to be the job creators in a
country around the world
just like america because i think the
idea of capitalism only lasts about 100
years here's what i mean by
when when a person becomes rich you
create wealth
i'm your kid say i learned all your hard
work
hypothetically so i watched that and my
dad worked his tail off he was
oh my gosh it was constantly working
fine i pick up some of it one of your
kids is gonna resent you
maybe you weren't around he was never on
my practice he was never so you're gonna
have one your kids that's gonna resent
you and one of your kids is gonna go
and work as hard as you but the
grandkids
or the great grandkids one of them is
going to say i don't want to work like
you
i don't care about being a millionaire i
don't care about all that other stuff
and they're going to be have everything
handed to them
then eventually the concept of hard work
and
you know industrious and all this other
stuff goes away because somebody
eventually got the handouts in the
family
the grain kid or the great grandkid that
gets the handout screws up the entire
legacy of the family
right i look at that if america was a
family
you know the original founders created
this great country and all this other
stuff and that money
capital hasn't worked 100 years 250
years from 1903
1910 1920 now we're like well let us use
the money let's introduce taxes all this
other stuff so
i don't know i don't know what direction
this is going to go you know the one
thing i do want to ask you about is i
had john perkins on yesterday
i don't know if you know who john
perkins is he's the author of the
economic hit man maybe you remember the
first book that he wrote economic hitman
sold a few million copies
in 39 different languages and he wrote
the new one
and i had him on i asked him a lot of
different questions i said what's the
business model of what you did as an
economic hit man when you worked for a
company that worked directly with the
nsa
here's what he said he said i would go
to a country that had natural resources
and here's what i would do number one
we'd set up a meeting with the pm
or the ministry of finance he says we'd
have the meaning number two
i tell them look i represent xyz
how about if i go to world bank and i
raise five billion dollars
it's a loan to you with that loan we get
gmg whoever whatever big company to come
and build a plant here
and create jobs for you you pay that 5
billion
loan and on top of that any of your kids
if they want to go to harvard yale brown
will receive them we'll give them full
ride scholarship don't worry about it
and we'll give this much money to your
brother to your cousin to your sister
will take care of them then they say
very interesting
then they say by the way if you say no
to this
i just want to remind you what happened
to john doe the leader of indonesia and
to such and such the leader of
colombia look what happened to these i'm
just not saying we're going to do that
to you
but look what happened to them because
they said no so what would you like to
do
then the person's coordinator saying
okay i'll do it the two people that said
no to him they were killed
everybody else said yes to him then
eventually they come in they build the
infrastructure
the country's paying the loan they
default on the loan
then the country comes in and says we're
going to take away your oil we're going
to take away this and we get the
resources right
that's what he calls the economic hitman
okay
the question i asked is how much of that
business model
is being used from a china
to people like mcconnell and biden how
much of a model like that is being used
of economic hitmen that are coming and
saying we'll give you one and a half
billion dollars to this venture capital
fund
and pay 50 000 a month on xyz or we
understand your wife's
father owns a big construction company
you know wink wink just don't bash us a
lot leave us alone let us do what we're
doing
how much of that is being used today
against american politicians not the
other way around
well the answer is um a lot and we see
this
um this is what the ukraine scandal was
all about involving the biden family
think about it we're not even dealing
with russia or china we're dealing with
a small country ukraine
and what does ukraine do the moment that
joe biden has made the point man
for ukraine the ukrainian energy company
called barisma
immediately puts hunter biden his son
on the board and starts paying hunter
biden and his partner
a hundred thousand dollar eighty three
000 a month
83 000 and this is a guy with no
background in energy
no background in the ukraine so what's
going on here
is that in other countries where
corruption by the way is
is normal they realize that when you are
dealing with america
you cannot give money to joe biden
because if you give money to joe biden
he has to declare it he's under all
kinds of
of requirements to declare but his
brother james biden is not his other
brother frank biden is not
and his son hunter biden is not so other
countries are smart enough to figure out
listen don't do deals with joe biden
it's going to be corrupt and we're going
to be involved in a major corruption
scandal
do deals with family members of american
politicians obviously
we can then expect favorable treatment
from those politicians
so this is a very dirty business um and
part of the reason they get away with it
is that the american politicians are
willing to play along and so we've seen
in america
politicians grow enormously rich from
politics
this never used to be the case by the
way i mean fdr was a rich man so were
the kennedys
but nobody would claim that uh you know
that
jimmy carter got rich from politics
nobody would claim that
that um ronald reagan got rich from
politics or
even truman but we have seen the
net worth of the clintons basically went
from zero to 200 million dollars of the
bidens
zero to a hundred million dollars al
gore has a hundred million dollars
and again the point to make is that you
know it's one thing if these guys
started a business they made a product
that no one thought of
they were very successful with some new
innovation but no they've done none of
this they've produced
nothing what they've done is they have
sold access
to their political connections and
they're making they're doing it for a
big wad of cash
so this is an example of how america is
now becoming
more like the rest of the world which is
to say
corruption is a normal way of doing
business the business of politics
let me ask you this other question so
which is kind of along the lines of that
uh uh there are assassinations
which is a kennedy a lincoln an attempt
on reagan
and uh uh one many many years ago that
most people don't know about it's been
four of them three of them successful
one of them wasn't right
there is the you know various
uh traditional when i say traditional is
what's happened it's
assassination you come you take
someone's life and boom this person's
too controversial lincoln
you're not allowing us to make money
you're hurting us because
these slaves are allowing us to do a lot
of other things listen we don't like you
you're the first republican president we
got to take this guy out
uh hey john f kennedy we kind of don't
like what you're doing and you guys want
to go from
oil standard to gold standard and feds
and all this other stuff look you're
gonna hurt a lot of us we're not cool
with that
we got to do something over here hey you
know ronald reagan what are you doing
with all this other stuff you're dealing
with hey
you can't be doing this okay let's just
say those assassination attempts were
made
what what are some other methods of
assassination that doesn't have to do
with
killing a president and the reason why
i'm asking this question is because
sometimes and i know this is going to
sound like a strange comment to make
sometimes a direct assassination is
a lot less painful on the legacy than a
another method of assassination
from you being somebody that studied
history of what
the games that are being played
politically what are some methods of
assassination that could take place with
our existing president
well you've actually said something very
profound which is that assassination
weirdly tends to improve your historical
reputation
um kennedy for example was in for not
even two years i don't believe
uh and we the whole myth of camelot
you know assassination created the myth
of the kennedys the legend of the
kennedys if you will
uh to some degree that's also true of
lincoln lincoln was very controversial
when he was president
he barely got um elected uh and then his
re-election was also
a big open question until you know until
he went some military victories right
before
election day um and it was assassination
that turned lincoln into sort of the the
legend that he
he became now i think today
the more common technique of going after
someone
is ultimately to blacken their
name uh to use what can be called the
deep state and i want to be precise
about this because i'm not i'm not
talking about any kind of conspiracy
theory
so we have in america these police
agencies of the government
let's name some of them the fbi the cia
the doj the department of justice uh the
irs
so these agencies are set up to do
something
which is to neutrally and fairly enforce
the law
so for example you think of the fbi as
as tracking down criminals
but what if you could get some criminals
into the fbi
at the top level so that instead of
being thugs on the street you have thugs
with badges
thugs running the very agency that is
supposed to go after the thugs
now this is a very dangerous situation
because now
they have the power of the badge and the
power of arrest
and the power of of the authority to
indict and they can go after their
political opponents
so this would be a form of i would call
it political assassination because it's
not intended to kill you
but it's intended to destroy your career
destroy your credibility um
maybe put you into handcuffs but put you
out of commission
i think to be honest my own case was
intended somewhat like that
it was not ultimately intended to you
know they don't they don't necessarily
want to lock me up they want to
discredit me they want me not to be a
public figure speaking out
they want to isolate me from my own
supporters and fans
and that is the purpose of this
political hit
so we've seen more of that in recent
years a very disturbing trend the
corruption of the police agencies of
government
at the high level now the ordinary fbi
agent is fine he's just doing his job
just like the ordinary cop is doing his
job for the most part
but when it's corrupt at the high level
it's very important to root that out
okay so you got political assassination
character assassination what other
models are there
financial assassination uh and that is
that can be done
by and large through the mechanism of
the lawsuit
so for example let's just say you're a
business guy a company will come to your
so a left-wing organization will come to
you and say listen you've got to give a
million dollars to black lives matter
and you go why they go because if you
don't we'll accuse you of being a racist
or we will file a civil rights lawsuit
against you so what happens is companies
live in the terror
of not only the actual financial cost of
the lawsuit
but also the reputational cost that will
make you stigmatize
will put a scarlet letter on you if you
will and so it turns you into a coward
you basically go okay
well here's the check you know you fill
in the amount
or what do you want me to say i'll take
a knee i'll do this so all of this is is
a sign of people
and when fear governs a society
people are turned into worms i mean
you've seen this in iran
um and it occurs in many other countries
in the world intimidation is used as a
regular tactic to
keep the citizenry cowed cow means
you're up against the wall
and you won't dare to do something that
will that will cause
trouble for the people in power so we
got political character and financial
and by the way part of the financial
could also be taxes and irs which we've
seen that as well
but you know the reason why i'm asking
this is
you know you're seeing a lot of that
but you're probably seeing them more
today than ever before and one has to
know if you get into politics this is
you know for the risk that you could see
so
if they can't there seems to me the
there seems to be this desire that we
have to do whatever we can to get this
man out of the white house
whatever we can to get this man out of
the white house when i see that
i didn't see that with george w bush
i didn't see that with bill clinton on a
second term i didn't see that with obama
on his second term
yeah just kind of yeah well you know we
got to make sure romney wins no he lost
okay
bill you know bill o'reilly and uh
dennis miller went on a tour talking
about what happened or
jon stewart and bill o'reilly were
debating oh no we got to get
you know bush out because you guys got
to be careful about what happens yeah
okay i'll go
fine no problem but it wasn't like this
what is it about trump that is
gotten people that passionate to get
them out
is it because trump's gonna do something
on second term with this q anon that
you're hearing about
a you know secret organization ran by
two military former generals that are
gonna
bring out the deep state is it because
of
what you're hearing about with epstein
that maybe some things are going to be
revealed that two politicians video
which elaine maxwell that if it comes
out
is it because roe v versus wade is it
because of
you know obamacare is what is what is
the biggest thing where you're seeing
this level of passion to say
we got is is it fear is it something we
don't know what do you think it is
you know i i think it's it's a very um
the reason it's so strange the
phenomenon you're describing
um we call it trump derangement syndrome
you know this
kind of virus of of um losing your mind
when the name trump comes up what makes
it even doubly strange is many of the
people who suffer the most acute cases
of trump derangement syndrome
were massive donald trump fans in the
old days
in other words the same people who say
things like trump is a dictator
trump is an authoritarian are the kind
of people who love trump when trump
would show up on larry king and trump
was on the apprentice and rappers were
writing songs about trump and trump was
you know there with al sharpton marching
down you know fifth avenue
so the irony about trump is it's not
that he's
an unknown guy who's like come out of
nowhere and
and people are really scared this is a
guy who's been a staple of american
popular culture
for 30 years he's been a figure that
most of us i mean people in america have
grown up with trump
right and and there's something very
all-american about trump i mean even his
weaknesses are very all-american he's
got a he's like that kid
who grew up in queens where you know
even if you are some unimportant guy if
you attack him he has to attack you back
you know he's
he's just got that scrappy new york
personality
which is so recognizable to anyone who
lives in the city
um so this is trump he he is who he is
um and i think that americans didn't
expect a guy like him um
and he does threaten a lot of the
conventional ways of doing business in
america and doing politics in america
uh even in the republican party this is
the the the source of the so-called
never trump
movement it's republicans who thought
that they had figured out a kind of a
comfortable way of doing business and
it's almost like
bringing in a new ceo into a company who
comes in and goes
the reason we've been losing money is a
lot of you aren't doing your job and i'm
going to be shaking things
up from the inside and immediately
there's an effort to get rid of the guy
because he poses such a lethal threat to
all the comfortable
you know nuclei of power that have
established himself all the competing
fiefdoms go oh wow
you know here's a new guy in charge and
we got to push him out before he does
any more damage
i wonder if it's just that that's what i
wonder i wonder if it's just that
because
to me that happens all the time so the
new ceo comes he fires a bunch of people
he brings his own team
the old guys work and still stay in
contact with the employees that are
working at the home office and they
bicker and [ __ ] and some people still
have some kind of a control
and then eventually they're over it
because they have new problems and a
year later two years that everybody
moves on right
but this is different i mean you have to
agree that this isn't just a guy coming
in to
i don't know i i i don't know i don't
know what it is and
uh you know i'm a business guy i'm not a
guy that's in the world to know
everything to
really dig deep and investigate to know
what really is the reason why people are
so afraid of him what is it
you know are we gonna find out on the
second term i don't know i don't know
what's going on over there but i'm uh
i'm just curious curious you know what
it is well the surface explanations
don't make sense because you listen to
people who say on msnbc you know trump
is an authoritarian i'm thinking wait a
minute trump is bashed
on every platform every second of every
day
right if you tried to do that to say
mussolini what would happen to you
first of all goons would show up at cnn
they would beat everybody up and shut
the place down that would be the end of
it
one time you do it and then that's the
last time but with trump it's not the
case i mean with trump
people are speaking out with no fear
people are rioting with no fear people
are pulling down public monuments with
no fear
so whatever trump is he's not an
authoritarian
um and um so i think you're right there
is something deeper going on something
that is a combination of i mean i think
you mentioned some of the factors roe
versus wade that's part of it
because there is a worry that the court
the balance of the court will shift
i don't think it's going to shift that
much at least not not anytime soon look
at the way that that
roberts for example has now taken on the
kennedy role of being the swing vote
so it's not obvious that the court is
going to dramatically swing one way or
the other it's kind of precariously in
the middle which it has been for 25
years
uh but trump gets him in a way nobody
does um he has an effect on people that
it has
almost has to be seen to to be believed
yeah i uh um i uh we were invited we
went to the mar-a-lago event that he had
a few months ago
and where you know the president was the
prime minister of brazil that got the
coronavirus that same event we were
there ourselves and when you see him you
see the energy
off-camera slightly different than on
camera the way he tells the story
you know he knows how to win the crowd
and when i went there i took people that
were against them
we took seven guests and we went there
you know just to kind of see
how people would view it and uh you know
very interesting personality who he is
very i mean i read ordered a deal 20
years ago 19 years ago and i said what a
great book
yeah i got a bunch of copies that i've
had for years prior to him being
president i would always give it away to
my guys hey learn how to negotiate
read this book but uh i don't know you
know
to me i just think he needs way more
secret service than other presidents
have needed in the past
i don't know and i think you know i um
yeah my family had a meeting with him uh
last november and uh it turned out to be
a 45-minute meeting
um and it was very illuminating because
my wife said to him something like she
said you know mr president she goes
you're attacked
so viciously in the media an ordinary
person would be completely
demoralized would go under his desk you
know how do you take it
you know um and we kind of expected
trump to laugh it off and go well you
know i enjoy it it's hilarious i love
bashing these people and so on but no he
was
he actually said the unexpected thing he
goes well guys you know he goes i gotta
tell you
just between us it it gets to me he goes
you know
because i'm working he goes i'm working
really hard for the american people he
goes
we just did this operation against kasim
solomoni
he goes this very difficult operation it
was carried out to perfection
he goes but these guys won't give me any
credit for anything
whatever i do must be bad if i recommend
a drug it's got to be the drug that
doesn't work
if i do an operation it's got to be the
worst operation ever and so i think he
said at the end of the day it's
it's a little you know it does get to me
and i for us
it was a it was seeing a vulnerable side
of trump
that we didn't quite expect and i know
my wife was a little startled by it
uh and a little moved by it yeah you
know but but
i understand that and i i can fully see
that
but at the same time if you bring in
that new york uh
attitude and you cannot be surprised if
that's what's happening you just cannot
be surprised if you're just
going after people as quickly as fast as
you are with twitter and
non-stop you just have to if you're
bullying the bully you're you're still
hurting the
the other bully that you're bullying his
ego is going to get hurt then
it's just gonna be counseling back and
forth you know you punch somebody
they're gonna punch you back so
it's non-stop gonna happen but uh you
know dinesh uh
the last thing i was gonna ask you is
you told a story in the in your
documentary about saulinski back in 1970
i think george
um senior boy senior was given the talk
and you know protesters were coming in
saying hey what's the best way for us to
protest
and i'll let you tell the story but uh
that is a pretty riveting story if
that's an accurate story so
what happened when these protesters when
i had a meeting with saul lindsay and by
the way for some people that don't know
who he is maybe you can elaborate on who
he is
that gave that advice so lelinski was a
political organizer you can almost call
him the original community
organizer he was a an inspiration to
both barack obama and hillary clinton
obama when he graduated from harvard law
school
went to work for the olinsky
organization hillary clinton wrote her
thesis on alinsky so this is a
figure that has had a huge impact
through his influence on
other powerful people and the story is
described in the biography of welinsky
by an olinsky supporter
it was about how clever alinsky was in
doing political sort of dirty tricks
and in this case what happened is that
george w h w bush the father was giving
a speech at the united nations
uh and a group of leftists from the 60s
came to olinsky and they were like why
don't we hold up signs that basically
equate
george w bush with like the ku klux klan
um
and alinsky was like well that's that's
a very crude and stupid thing to do
and of course you can do it but it's
unimaginative here's something more
clever
what about if you guys go out to a to
the local store and buy some white
sheets
uh why don't you come dressed up as ku
klux klansman yourselves
and then when george h.w bush starts
speaking you have all these signs and
you jump up and down and you go
were with bush kkk supports bush this is
much more effective because when it when
it's seen in the media
well people will see images horrific
images of people and white hoods
supporting bush this will do far more
damage to bush's credibility
than a group of hippies carrying signs
equating bush so
so basically alinsky was proposing
creating if you will a theater
a political theater in which you you you
manipulate the imagery
uh to send a false message but the false
message is believed to be true
because of the enormous power of the
media how
how accurate is that statement and how
has it been verified that that actually
was stated
well it is an uh i believe the source of
it is sanford horwitz book called let
them call me rebel which is a
this is a progressive leftist writing a
full length the only
full-length biography of olinsky
and i believe that is the source i've
documented it and footnoted in my own
work but i believe from memory
that that is the source of that
particular anecdote if you could send
that to me i'd like to put the link
below because to me that is just
uh uh i mean divisive but at the same
time
uh a model that we're seeing a lot of
today as well
which it kind of gets the average person
to sit there and say who do you really
trust on media like who do you really
believe in media when you see different
things like
who should i trust do i trust people on
the right do i trust left do i trust
tucker do i trust anderson do i trust
mata do i trust hannity who do i trust
it's very tough right now
for the average person i'm not talking
about for the person that already has a
political affiliation and they've done
a lot of reading and due diligence i'm
talking for the 60 70
voter that doesn't follow politics says
i don't know who i trusted it's a very
very weird time well
dinesh thank you so much for being a
guest on valuetainment folks i'm going
to put the link below
to uh his book uh united states of
socialism and
dinesh do we have a set date on when the
documentary will be coming out
it's been announced for august 7th but
as you know things are in a little flux
with the theater so we're in close
consultation with the
with our distributor to figure out the
best timing and the best way to release
this movie but
it's going to be coming out soon it's
going to be coming out this summer
we're gonna put the link to the
documentary as well at the bottom for
you to know exactly what data to be
released i just watched it
and uh i highly recommend people
watching and make your own opinion about
what's uh
being said in there in the documentary
it'll definitely make you think
uh on what is taking place today finish
i'll give you final thoughts before we
wrap up
we are a divided country uh we're
divided over very fundamental issues
i think it's a time for the ordinary
citizen to be more involved and more
informed
than normal just for the reason you just
said which is to say that these days
we can't automatically take for granted
the information that's put out there
a lot of it is manipulated some of it is
flatly untrue
and so documentaries like mine are aimed
at helping you to think in a new way
about what's really going on very cool
dinesh once again thank you for being a
guest on that team appreciate your time
my pleasure so what was your biggest
takeaway from this interview knowing
which way he leans politically what was
your biggest takeaway
specifically when we talk about
socialism against capitalism or the
indian
educational system the ranking of where
you're ranked or you know
different methods of assassination
political financial and uh
uh character uh what was your biggest
takeaway i want to hear your thoughts
and if you watch today's interview
and the concept of socialism you're
saying i want to know more about
socialism
i sat down with a professor who is a
very very well-known professor the
top marxist socialistic professor we
have in america richard wolff
and we had a friendly debate if you've
never watched it i highly recommend you
watch this debate he and i had
and if you've not watched my sit down
with roger stone because he talks about
the manipulation of politics and how it
works out if you've not watched this
click over here and if you've not
subscribed to the channel please do so
thanks for watching everybody take care
[Music]
bye